{\rtf1\ansi\ansicpg1252\cocoartf1038\cocoasubrtf360
{\info
}\vieww12240\viewh14820\viewkind1
\deftab720
\pard\pardeftab720\sl240\sa200\qc\pardirnatural
\f0\fs40 \cf0 2012-06-26_rosemarie\
\pard\pardeftab720\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b\fs24 \cf0 [0:00:00]\
\b0 Colin: This is in some sense I guess we
met maybe a year -- about a year ago.\
Rosemarie: I think so.\
\pard\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Colin: Which seems like ever so very
long ago because we gathered group of people
who were thinking about accessibility from
a variety of different perspectives and her
resume was clearly the star of the show in
bringing a really unique and powerful perspective
to our conversations and helping me -- absolutely
challenging the Berkman Center to do better
on issues of accessibility and accessing to
also not just to do better but to really rethink
our ideas about accessibility to technology,
to learn from universal design, to learn from
some of the other experiences that we've seen
in architecture, urban planning, design and
about twenty five other disciplines. \
\pard\pardeftab720\li2160\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 She comes to us from Emory where she's
a Professor of Women's Studies and English
by way of Radcliffe down the road where she
has been a fellow this past year. But I think
has a really powerful perspective on critical
but maybe she calls critical disability stage
as least that's how I think of it and being
most wonderfully critical but in a wonderfully
constructive way. And I think it's a really
important dialog for us to have and then continue
with and follow the dialog up with action.
So one of the reasons I'm so thrilled to have
all of the interns in this room for you is
because these are the ones who are going to
be making that stuff happen. And so I am hopeful
and confident that you will infect them with
your particular side of vision and that you
guys will challenge her in ways that shows
how much she really has to offer.\
\pard\pardeftab720\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Rosemarie: Thank you.\
Colin: So please, welcome Rosemarie.\
Rosemarie: Thank you. Thank you.
\b [Clapping]
\b0 I'm not sure if this Colin?\
Colin: Okay. \
Rosemarie: Can you hear all that?\
Female 1: Yeah.\
Rosemarie: Okay. Great.\
Colin: I'm good.\
\pard\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Rosemarie: Well, welcome and thank you
very much coming. Colin, thank you for this
opportunity and the invitation to be here
at the Berkman Center and to share the work
that I do in Critical Disability Studies which
we take, of course, the term from Critical
Ways Studies or sometimes we call our work
Cultural Disability Studies. So I'm here to
basically tell you and show you what an accessible
world we live in right now at this moment
in this place and I'm going to emphasize the
idea of my title here
\i Expanding the Concept of Accessible Technology
\i0 . I have a lot of images so that I can
show and tell at the same time and I'm going
to try to go through them quickly in order
to be highly illustrative about the rather
simple points that I want to make.\
\pard\pardeftab720\li2160\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 This has a hair trigger.
\b [Laughter]
\b0 So my purpose today is to expand the idea
of accessible technology and to show you the
way we make our shared world of buildings,
of technologies, of public spaces, practices,
laws, culture and attitude and how it builds
a total environment which welcomes some people
and keeps other people out. So the talk is
going to present an evolution of how accessible
-- technologies in the very broadest sense
make our citizenry more inclusive and diverse.
So the principle that I'm going to be illustrating
to you today is that accessible technology
is everywhere once you know how to look for
it. \
Okay. People with disabilities, of course,
have always use technology to participate
in a world that's not built for them. For
most of history, of course, disabled people
out in public have been beggars. The figure
of the crippled or the blind beggar accessing
public space with technology appears often
in such well-known artworks as the ones I'm
showing you here, the 1525 painting by Pieter
Bruegel or this 1916 photograph of a blind
beggar by the American photographer Paul Strand.
\
\pard\pardeftab720\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b \cf0 [0:05:06]\
\pard\pardeftab720\li2160\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b0 \cf0 So these are disabled folks using
technology to access the public world. Disabled
people participate in and contribute to the
world by using innovative technologies to
bridge the gap between their distinctive ways
of being in the world and a material and a
social environment that's built for standard
bodies but we sometimes call and I like this
term a lot "majority bodies".
\b [Laughter]
\b0 The writer and the intellectual Helen
Keller, for example, used a human interpreter
to facilitate communication. She's a 1908
graduate of Radcliffe, by the way, whereas
as the physicist Stephen Hawking uses a machine
for communication and mobility.\
Most technology that human beings use exclude
people with disabilities because the designs
are either inflexible or only support standard
bodies. In our contemporary moment, however,
distinctive technologies designed to be used
by people with disabilities are emerging from
the developed world. For instance, and I hope
you're all following this, double amputee
Oscar Pistorius uses fibre-carbon prosthetic
legs made down the road here at MIT to compete
against runners with fleshly legs and he is
trying to qualify to run in the Olympics,
not the Paralympics and has until I think
three or four days to do it. \
To suggest the expansion and the evolution
of an accessible technology, I'm going to
lay out for you today as I suggested two opposing
kinds of what I call World Building. Both
are material and historical initiatives that
shaped communities by determining who and
who does not participate in these communities.
One of these is eugenic world building. The
other is inclusive world building. And I'm
going to start with eugenic world building
but I'm going to emphasize the inclusive world
building but I want to spend a little bit
of time laying out a contrast here so that
you have a sense of the logic and the history
of what I called eugenic world building. \
So eugenic world building was a progressive
and this is important, initiative carried
out primarily in the first half of the 20th
century worldwide but most fully in the developed
West that's because they had technology and
delivered -- I'm sorry. That is intended to
shape a desired citizenry by producing more
of the people that any given group considers
as valuable and by eliminating the people
that are considered to inferior. So things
like Better Baby Contests and Fitter Family
Competitions were common practices to define
and to show what a desired citizen might be
like. These are examples this Better Baby
Contests of what is sometimes called positive
eugenics. \
Negative eugenics was carried out, of course,
at the same time through laws and medical
practices in the United States and elsewhere
in the developed world through primarily forced
sterilization which happened extensively in
the United States. The famous 1927 Supreme
Court decision authorized forcible sterilization.
Supreme Court Justice Oliver Wendell Holmes
explained the logic of this negative eugenics
policy by asserting quite famously the quote
"Three generations of imbeciles is enough."
\
Nazi Germany enacted, of course, the ultimate
logic of negative eugenics beginning in September
1939 by rounding up and exterminating several
hundred thousand disabled Germans who were
in institutions that range from orphanages
to medical care facilities. They transferred
them to extermination facilities with the
Nazi's in cooperation with medical practitioners
developed the gas chambers and the sham medical
exams which were later used in a much more
ambitious Nazi project to exterminate the
Jews of Europe and other groups who were considered
to be eugenically inferior. \
Today, across the developed world, reproductive
technologies carry out a kind of negative
eugenics aimed at eliminating disability and
people born with disabilities under the logic
of individual choice and we might want to
think a little bit about the more recent development
of the population imbalance that's taking
place in developing countries as a result
of sex selection abortion which is in some
sense the eugenic undertaking.\
\pard\pardeftab720\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b \cf0 [0:10:27]\
\pard\pardeftab720\li2160\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b0 \cf0 Princeton philosopher Peter Singer
advocates that the disable newborns should
be euthanized on the basis of parental discretion
and there's a quote here by Peter Singer "We
think that some infants with severe disabilities
should be killed." And he holds to that philosophical
position to this day. \
Now, for a cheerier topic
\b [Laughter]
\b0 , what I'm calling inclusive world building
is a way of thinking which strives to make
a world in which a diverse range of human
beings can use effectively and participate
fully. Inclusive world building is a set of
legal and material practices born of the civil
and the human rights movement of the mid 20th
century that changed the composition of the
citizenry who could fully participate in all
aspects of civil life and some of this legislation
you are aware of is in constant the Americans
with Disabilities Act of 1990 and 2009 as
well as the worldwide United Nations Treaty
and the Rights of People with Disabilities
which was enacted in 2008.\
For the rest of my time today, I'm going to
present you aspects of inclusive world building
developed and enacted as a direct result of
the legal and the material initiatives that
developed that with the human and civil rights
movement. Inclusive design is a guiding principle
of world building that has transformed the
built environment by allowing a wide diversity
of citizens previously excluded to enter in
to and use the world that we have built together
and that we share in order for them to use
and to exercise the privileges and the obligations
of a democratic citizenship, so inclusive
design. \
What I'm calling inclusive design is a principle
of world making as express through a variety
of terms some of which you might be familiar
with, inclusive design, design for all, universal
design, human-centered design, barrier-free
design. One definition that I like to put
forward that I've developed is inclusive design
is human-centered design of everything with
everyone in mind and I'm going to try to show
you some examples. I want to take a moment
to call attention to the Iconography of Inclusive
World Building. As a way to kind of gestured
to the varying solutions that human communities
have developed to extend the opportunity to
ex -- previously excluded citizens to participate
in civic life. So the international symbol
of access I love this because it's both an
icon and a sign as well a material technology
of accessibility that calls the attention
to the accessible features of the built environment
that actually tend to go unnoticed because
we routinary use them. So these various icons
that I'm going to scroll through very quickly
become signs in both senses of the world of
an accessible environment for us, all of us,
to notice and to use collectively. \
So the sign for way finding for people with
low vision or anyone, for us way finding challenges?
The sign language interpretation which I think
is a particularly elegant symbol. Volume control
telephone symbol here provides accessibility
in communication, of course, family restrooms
which have transformed life for all of us.
\b [Laughter]
\b0 Single-use restrooms allow a variety of
different people including, and this is really
interesting recently, transsexual people to
appropriately use restrooms. \
\pard\pardeftab720\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b \cf0 [0:15:02]\
\pard\pardeftab720\li2160\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b0 \cf0 I like this the best.
\b [Laughter]
\b0 I call this renegade access symbols
\b0 that are what I call the cloud source
iconography of access that has emerged from
the bottom up. This is on the left, a -- an
initiative undertaken by actually someone
in the room here to promote a redesigned more
agentic as it were symbol of accessibility
and to overlay that on the more aesthetic
symbol that that has been developed. And then
my favorite one, I didn't even know where
this came from is it's a directional icon
for disabled sex
\b [Laughter]
\b0 which is important, another really quite
wonderful sexuality-oriented piece of iconography.\
Okay. I want to go through a number of images
that are illustrative of inclusive world building
at work to call your attention to some of
these features that we all experience and
use often times without realizing that we
are accessing technologies that make the world
more diverse for all of us. So before I do
that, I have a list here as well as some illustrations
of the principles of universal design if you
wish to take a look at those. They are a little
bit hard understand but it's worth investigating
at later, equitable used, flexibility in use,
simple and intuitive, perceptible information,
low tolerant or tolerance for error, low aesthetical
effort, size and space. I don't know why the
force in there. Approach and use -- I use
dictations that -- technology which has the
really funny little ticks and also some hilarious
things. My favorite one is that sometimes
when I say to my technology accessible, it
comes out E-X-C-E-S-S-I-V-E, new word, B-U-L-L.
\b [Laughter]
\b0 Excessivebull.
\b [Laughter]\
\pard\pardeftab720\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b0 \cf0 Male 1: Do you say that's not it?
\b [Laughter]\
\b0 Rosemarie: Absolutely.\
Male 1: It\'92s been in there. It's very high-tech.\
\pard\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Rosemarie: That's exactly right. So the
drinking fountain at multiple heights, the
push buttons that allows doors to open for
people who use wheelchairs or are carrying
lots of packages or children or anything else.
So ease of manipulation is important. The
universal leather handle doors instead of
the round doorknobs provide universal accessibility
to everyone. It's an elegant example and they
are also beautiful. Threshold-free access,
long ramps and curb cuts and you're seeing
illustrations and I'll talk a little bit more
about that, varying kinds of wheels mobility.
We have some elegant designs that have evolved
for wheelchair usage. For example, in airports,
you are seeing more and more and more people
using wheelchairs to navigate the long distances
that are required to travel in our mega airports
these days. \
\pard\pardeftab720\li2160\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 There are also walkers that are particularly
elegant and useful kinds of accessible mobility,
accessible technology. Multiple usage wheel
to access -- I talk a lot about the invention
of wheeled luggage which occurred contemporaneously
with the changes in the built environment
to ramp it so that we are able now to have
those all-terrain vehicle strollers for a
parents to be able to access public transportation
and spaces that they were kept out of before
as well as wheeled luggage which is perhaps
one of the most universal of all technologies.
I like this concept accessible sanitary system.
These are particularly elegant design solutions.
\
Architectural elegance, of course, we know
this now that the legislation in the US and
elsewhere has been underway for about thirty
years or more, architecture beginning to develop
some beautiful and elegant solution besides
simply shoving an ugly ramp on the front of
an old building. And here some examples, there's
often a conflict between preserving historical
integrity and creating access but architects
and designers are beginning to come up with,
again, elegant and an effective solutions
for this.\
\pard\pardeftab720\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b \cf0 [0:20:01]\
\pard\pardeftab720\li2160\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b0 \cf0 This is a cathedral with a really
lovely ramp. Accessible transportations systems,
I'd like to focus on a little bit in a sense
that in a democratic capitalist order one
of the most aspects of this, the world we
live in now is mobility in every sense and
the transportation is the key to mobility
in every sense. So accessible transportation
systems such as the DC Metro offer wide variety
of access. I love this particular illustration.
This is a woman getting on an accessible piece
of transportation with her service honny [0:20:42]
[Phonetic].
\b [Laughter]
\b0 \
We have brailed information services in public
places and in accessible transportation. Service
animals of course have access to -- public
transportation. Cane navigation is facilitated
by technologies and public transportation
elsewhere. Multiple vertical transportation
modes exist in most public transportation;
elevators, escalators, stairs and climb paths.
Multiple linguistic access; English language
signage, Spanish signage. This is from the
Washington DC Metro symbolic signage, universal
signage and most interestingly what I call
non-literate signage which we often see. \
Various stability aids are very important.
Here we have, of course, someone using stability
aids in order to have an infant-carrying wheeled
device on a metro car. Train platform continuities
are very important for wheel to access from
platform in to subway and train cars. I'll
take a little bit more now about accessible
communication devices. If I had an hour and
a half, I would go on and on about my love
affair with the iPhone and the iPad
\b [Laughter]
\b0 , the newly accessible one which has changed
my life and made it possible for me to do
work. I'll talk a little bit more about that.
\
There are apps in the iPhone and the iPad
that are universally accessible. You don't
have to download them separately. I think
many of you know about this. You simply can
turn them on for a variety of different access
features. There are apps that use amazing
kinds of, I don't know, programs. I'm never
good at talking about this but for example,
allow people to communicate using sign language
with FaceTime or there are some really interesting
apps. I don't know, again, how to use that.
This is a picture of a woman with low vision
or blind who is using her iPhone to take pictures
of cans and are covered and then somehow it
goes somewhere and somehow something tells
her what's... there you go, what's in her
covered. Simple things, of course, like varying
side text, enlargeable text, we know and use
these features often.\
This is a picture of me using the iPhone and
the iPad technology which works really well
for me. I don't have a very iconic disability.
I have a rather distinctive disability. Therefore,
I have particular needs and the iPhone has
made it possible for me to text in a way that
I couldn't possibly do before and has made
communicating and creating texts extremely
accessible for me so that I can do my work
and be out and about in the world. \
Okay. The last thing that I want to talk about
is perhaps most the -- the most counter intuitive
and distinctive aspect of accessible technology
and that is what I call art and culture as
a form of accessible technology. So the entry
of people with disabilities of course and
other people that have been excluded previously
on the basis of category such as race and
gender has given them access to social capital
such as education, employment, acculturation
and social networks which has produced a flourishing
disability culture in which accessible technology
is a crucial component and I'm going to try
to show you how accessible technology is implicated
and fundamental to producing disability art
and culture. Okay, more recent popular television
shows such as Glee introduced accessible technologies
and people with disabilities to add both hip
diversity and cheerful theatricality to the
plots.\
\pard\pardeftab720\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b \cf0 [0:25:08]\
\pard\pardeftab720\li2160\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b0 \cf0 So we have wheelchairs and actual
people with disabilities in such television
shows as Glee. Civil rights lawyer and author
Harriet McBryde Johnson has engaged that philosopher
Peter Singer in to a public debate in the
New York Times about his advocacy for euthanizing
disabled newborns. So not only medical and
mechanical technology provided access to education
and economic resources for people like Harriet
McBryde Johnson but communication technology
put Johnson and her ideas before a wide general
public. \
The photographer Kevin Connolly who was born
legless and travels the world on a low riding
kind of skateboard that he prefers over a
wheelchair for mobility has reversed the photographic
gaze that's established by artists such as
Diane Arbus by photographing thousands of
people across the world that he has captured
looking at him. The distinctive angle of his
camera and the surprise that he captures on
the faces and the postures of the people looking
at him, turns back their looks upon them and
reveals their surprise at encountering such
an unusual person out and about in the world
using the accessible world and accessible
technology. You can go to his website and
see is 3,000 photographs.\
The entry of disabled people in to the world
and the media has produce the cadre, I love
this part, of disabled celebrities whose stories
and images range much beyond earlier disabled
celebrities such as Helen Keller or even Stephen
Hawking. One example is the fashion model,
actress, champion runner and TED lecturer
Aimee Mullins with fashion model good looks
and a shape that's very Barbiesque.
\b [Laughter]
\b0 Mullins is also a double amputee and she
quips that disability is a great advantage
as a fashion model because she can make herself
as tall as she wants to be.
\b [Laughter]
\b0 And she has a wide variety of prosthetic
and functional and cosmetic legs that she
uses and proudly displays in all kinds of
public performances of disability and femininity
and accessibility in the world. \
The blind author Georgina Kleege has a series
of really wonderful books that I've been highly
recommend. She's written a book called Sight
Unseen which investigates the metaphoric of
sight and the blindness in the world. And
she has a wonderful epistolary set of personal
essays called Blind Rage; it's one of the
best titles ever, Letters to Helen Keller.
\
I think the most radical development and impromptutation
[0:28:16] [Phonetic] of accessible has emerge
in disability of visual art -- disability
art in general. The subjects of the portraits
that I'm presenting here have been traditionally
characterized as people with disease, deformity,
disfigurement and I'd suggest, however, that
these kinds of paintings begin to show us
how we might reimagine disability through
aesthetics accessible technologies not as
a form inferiority that we want to eliminate
from the human condition but rather perhaps
a form of rare beauty. \
This is one of Harriet McBryde Johnson's terms
that I think is really important and interesting
and out there as a kind of form of aesthetic
accessible technology that I'll talk about
a little bit in the remainder of my time here.
Disability aesthetics, I want to suggest is
a form of accessible technology that enables
us to understand embodiment and subjectivity
in new ways. Art, photography and painting
has captured some of the ways that this rare
beauty can be found in disability. It's a
beauty I suggest that emerges from distinctiveness
rather than ordinariness, from struggle rather
than comfort and from the unusual rather than
the usual. This is a photograph of fashion
shoot by the photographer, an English photographer,
Knight -- Nick Knight and the late designer,
English designer Alexander McQueen who designed
the series of costumes in a photo shoot called
Accessible. \
\pard\pardeftab720\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b \cf0 [0:30:04]\
\pard\pardeftab720\li2160\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b0 \cf0 This is also a photograph on the
right of the model and the dancer Catherine
Long who is born partially armless. It's a
really interesting sculptural posture in which
her shoulder, her disarmed shoulder I want
to call it that is extended up and her arm
is hanging down in a really beautiful sculptural
pose. The entry of disability in to contemporary
dance is one of the most vibrant stories of
how accessible technology can facilitate and
evolution of artistic form. The introduction
of the wheelchair in to dance has been suggested.
I love this. It's the most important innovation
in contemporary dance since the toe shoe in
ballet. \
So I'm going to show you -- oh... Okay. So
one of the most interesting and controversial
uses of accessible technology in theatrical
artistic production comes from none other
than Lady Gaga who uses disability technology
such as wheelchairs, crutches and eye patches
as a kind of sensationalist fashion set of
accessories and costuming in a music videos
and in her live performances. In July 2011,
Lady Gaga rolled out for a performance in
Sydney using a wheelchair and a sensationalist
performance of what I called disability drag.
In my view, the cultural work of using accessible
technology associated with disabled people
-- scroll down a little bit here. Well, all
right. Let's see if this works. How do I get
the mouse -- I mean how do to get the cursor
there?\
\pard\pardeftab720\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Colin: Someone --\
\pard\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Rosemarie: Oh, okay. Thank you. I'll
do it. Okay, we're going to see...
\b [Music]
\b0 Lady Gaga is getting out of a limousine.
Giving a wheelchair.
\b [Laughter]
\b0 Outfit. What I want to suggest, of course,
is that to use -- to use disability technologies
as a form theatrical costuming, moves what
we thought of as a medicalized disability
prosthesis out of the world of medical stigmatization
in to the world of high fashion and celebrity
which I think does some pretty interesting
cultural work. \
\pard\pardeftab720\li2160\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 So I' going to finish with a clip here.
This is disabled dancer Bill Shannon who goes
by the stage name Crutch Man. He has evolved
a new dance form and set of choreographic
moves using crutches that he requires, this
is important, for mobility to fashion them
with a kind of rocker bottoms. So this is
a very distinctive kind of technology that
he himself developed accessible technology
in order to develop new break dancing moves.
Moreover and I think this is really important,
we can talk about this if it's of interest
to you, Shannon's dancing is so compelling
to have been used in a mainstream advertisement
for Visa Credit Cards. Ugh. This is the entirety
of that.
\b [Music]
\b0 So Shannon sitting on a bench. He gets
up and grabs those crutches and break dancing
down the street.\
\pard\pardeftab720\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b \cf0 [0:35:00]\
\pard\pardeftab720\li2160\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b0 \cf0 Rides down the baluster. Then glides,
pause\'85
\b [loud music on the background]
\b0 Break dance. Side walk. Hops again at
the ATM machine. Looking for access. Go to
another store.
\b [Laughter]
\b0 Now, without being an apologist for consumers
capitalism, I'd like to leave you with a thought
that is the difference between the 1525 crippled
of Pieter Bruegel who's only access to economic
resources with begging in the public sphere
and Bill Shannon, who's through accessible
technology and accessible world, an access
to the kinds of resources, social capital
that he needed actually has a job. Thank you.
\b [Clapping]
\b0 So I think we have maybe up to 30 minutes
for questions.\
\pard\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Colin: You have about half an hour. So
we put this and fearlessly dive in lots of
two often -- that which is very -- yeah. \
\pard\pardeftab720\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Rosemarie: I'm happy to fill any questions
or comments that you have.\
Colin: Thank you.\
Rosemarie: Please.\
\pard\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Female 2: Hi. Just a briefing -- I was
wondering when you were talking about the
different approaches of architecture that
have accessibilities sort of [0:37:16] [Inaudible].
There's a particular image I saw that does
a stairs a type actually like a wheelchair
in a ramp being sort of the main pull of the
stairs and then as -- at the height of the
ramp is now certainly go around the ramp.
And I'm just wondering if you would \'96 each
of this seems to me to be sort of [0:37:30]
[Inaudible] photograph that demonstrated in
the way that [0:37:37] [Inaudible] body technology
can build around accessible technology instead
of having the accessibilities. Sort of want
to have your thought.\
Rosemarie: Yes, I'm not -- I don't -- I'm
not an architect or a designer. So some of...
who are involved in that might be able to
explain it a little bit more but as I understand
that universal design as a principle, a set
of principles would put forward the concept
that there should be or that there might be
one form of access that is universal to all
rather than multiple modes of access for different
kinds of access. And I think those two ideas
are little bit intention and they are carried
out in different ways by different designers
and different architects in making the built
environment. I think it's actually quite interesting
to see multiple modes of access which would
be the kind of thing you're suggesting a ramp
next two stairs because it provides multiple
solutions and it provides people with alternatives.
\
\pard\pardeftab720\li2160\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 For example, ramps are not always the
most beneficial or the most efficient ways
for all people to access a change of vertical,
what is it called? Vertical, I don't know,
change of height -- that's not right but going
up, for a bunch of different reasons and so
I think that -- I think, personally, there's
a multiple design solutions to provide multiple
forms of access. That's certainly what public
transportation does. So we have elevators.
We have escalators. We have ramps, varying
ways of accessing a change of level. So thank
you. Other comments, question? Arguments?\
\pard\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Female 3: I have a question. It's really
interesting you bringing up Lady Gaga and
Glee and your disability drive with a fantastic
faith I hadn't heard before. And I agree your
point about kind of makes it more -- brings
it -- more people make practical and high
fashion but I was wondering if what your thoughts
were in terms of like even in Glee in one
episode, he gets up and walks and even in
the video you just showed, you know, first
Lady Gaga had to be picked up by, you know,
helpers and then later she's getting up and
walk -- \
\pard\pardeftab720\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Rosemarie: Got to be --\
[Crosstalk]\
\b [0:40:07]\
\b0 \
\pard\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Female 3: So a lot of these even in media
you see somebody who is in disability jive
then later casting that off in this miraculously
recovery almost. And I was wondering if that
might give like the wrong impression to some
people who may not be as familiar with minority
bodies as you say that, oh, it's this choice
that they're in the wheelchair. This choice
that using a technology even the fashion model,
you know, talks about the great things about
it which is cool in terms of she can change
her legs but at the same time she doesn't
have a choice to have --\
\pard\pardeftab720\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Rosemarie: Real legs?\
Female 3: Yeah, so I was just curious what
your thoughts were on that.\
\pard\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Rosemarie: No, that's a really good question
and of course, I am telling a very particular
kind of story. There is much controversy as
there always is in, you know, sort of democratic
public conversation about authenticity within
disability and also about varying stereotypes
of disabilities such as the concept of overcoming
ones disability, the idea of cure, the idea
of -- oh, I don't know, who ought and ought
not to be using these varying kinds of technologies
which is, again, kind of question of authorship
and authority all the way around. I think
that those are really vibrant and important
conversations. \
\pard\pardeftab720\li2160\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 I was just at the conference and someone
gave a paper on Lady Gaga and of course, was
-- there's a lot of condemnation and a lot
of understanding -- there's -- there's an
argument that would say that it's a trivializing
of disability by someone who doesn't need
to use a wheelchair and using it, I support
as, I'm sure you're able to see, a kind of
universalizing. For example, we've already
done that with the accessible technology of
glasses. You know, all you need to is look
at the New York Times for one second and you
see what's happened there. But of course,
that's also creating a market for accessible
technology but I think making technology inclusive
and available to everyone is a really important
democratic step so that for one thing, disability
status is the most poorest of all of the social
categories. We say often that if anyone who
lives long enough will become disabled eventually.
And so in some ways, being able to imagine
big glasses or wheelchair use or canes or
even hearing aids as fashion accessories early
on in life or at times in life when one is
able to occupy non-disabled status, I think
is a good practice. \
I just met a woman at a conference who has
-- who's hard of hearing and has been her
whole life and she had been using the kinds
of hearing aids that have been developed.
She uses one hearing aid in each year that
had been developed for kind of self -- self-hearing
aids, another words, that would look the very
most inconspicuous. And she said she finally
decided to get her hair cut off short because
she always had her hair long to cover up her
hearing aids. She got her hair cut short and
it's really hip hairdo and she got hearing
aids -- well then, she doesn't call them hearing
aids. There's another word for them now, inserts,
I think or something like that. That fills
in the inside of her whole ear that are purple
and I said to her, "You ought to get rhinestones
in them next.\'94
\b [Laughter]
\b0 \
And her purpose is twofold. I this is really
interesting. One is it's a disclosure method
so that she announces her status as hard of
hearing so that people are able to -- hearing
people are able to be in better communication
with her. They are better able to understand
who is it that they're dealing with and what
kinds of interactions are going to ensue from
this. And also, it's a bit of a disability
pride thing and it looks cool, plus her son
has the same hearing loss that she has and
you know, he's got blue ones. And she wanted
to be able to say, you know, here mommy's
there are purple, what color do you want and
you know, he has some that are red, white
and blue and a variety of different one. They
are fashion, you know, hearing aids and that
comes out of a disability pride movement that
would not have even possible thirty years
ago. And her life works better that way not
because she hears better with the technology
but because it's a technology that does other
kinds of things. It announces itself. Please.\
\pard\pardeftab720\sl240\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b \cf0 [0:45:03]\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b0 \cf0 Male 2: First, a quick comment just
about like you were just saying during one
of the NBA playoff games and the interview
afterwards Dwyane Wade was wearing a pair
of fake glasses, no lenses because he doesn't
have a visual problem but he was wearing at
style statement I looked online shortly there
after and there was a bunch of some comments
that people had made, you know, sort of about
that sort of urging celebrities to start wearing
fake hearing aids, hipster hearing aids they
were calling them. And --\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Rosemarie: Hipster hearing aids, that's
fabulous. Thank you. \
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Male 2: And so I did have a question
about creating inclusive design not as much
in the physical space but in the internet
and what your thoughts were about that, you
know, particularly, you know, and things like
streaming video for people with hearing issues
that's been a really big issue on struggle
in order to get companies to put captioning.
And so what your thoughts were on some principles
that would be, you know, good in the outline
space center. Perhaps what your thoughts of
all the, you know, statue in the law and court
cases like with them [0:46:18] [Phonetic].
\
\pard\tx2160\tx2445\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Rosemarie: Well, I can't say a lot about
that court cases and law. But you could to
Michael Stein over here in the Harvard Law
School who had the Disability Law Project.
I think it's called Disability and Law Project
and that's what he does. As I suggested, of
course, it is legislation that has rendered
the desegregation of people with disabilities
along with the desegregation of women and
people of color in the world. One of the main
differences and this is what I wanted to bring
forward is that there's a -- a distinct materiality
to that desegregation in terms of disability
access that is somewhat different from the
integration of women and the people of color
in to public space in the democratic order
since the Civil Rights Movement. \
And of course, it's interesting that the Civil
Rights Movements took place in the United
States and elsewhere but certainly in the
United States contemporaneously. They all
began more or less from the very late 1950's,
1960's, 1970's. We know about this what Harvard
was gender -- desegregated in the early 1970's,
that's just one example. And the Disability
Rights Movement which is interestingly enough
I didn't even know about until, you know,
I was well in to adulthood because it didn't
have as much play took place at the same time.
But it was carried out through these monumentally
important pieces of legislation just as gay
marriages being carried out or equality in
marriage, pardon me, is being carried out
in through the legal arena. Those decisions
have been made and that has transformed the
world. \
So technology, of course, needs to be accessible
also and it doesn't have the same kind of
materiality but there are guidelines and standards
for accessible technology. There is something
-- somebody have to help me out here called
Bobby which is a system of vetting and approval
that you can get if you're making a website
that's Bobby approved which means that it\'92s
accessible for, for example, people using
screen meters that's one of the main things.\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Male 3: It's also stands from WBC and
--\
Rosemarie: Right.\
\pard\tx2160\tx2445\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Male 3: And another word [0:48:55] [Inaudible].\
\pard\tx2445\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Rosemarie: Yeah, there's -- here's a
lot being done about accessible, the standards
and protocols for accessible technology. Another
really interesting development is Universal
Design and Learning, UDL which is a set of
principles pedagogical strategies that have
produced recommendations from multiple access
to learning that are fairly easily implemented
in the same way that we argued that curb cuts
are a really easily implemented if they're
built in instead of vaulted on and inexpensive.
That's same sort of theory is behind Universal
Design and Learning. So you can just look
at UDL and see a billion samples fill it by
[0:49:48] [Phonetic] and pedagogical strategies.
Please.\
Female 3: ... earlier. I'm just wondering
if you would talk a little bit to kind of
that keeps around the Universal Design. \
\pard\tx2445\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b \cf0 [0:50:00]\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\li2160\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b0 \cf0 I know that there are some challenges
to the idea particularly for those who are
in Magellan's [0:50:04] [Phonetic] Group saying
that universal design is really down play
their concerns of not being in the mainstream
that it can be a very mainstream, of course,
that says that leads are very instructional
issues are perhaps less important and while
that it helps to accommodate them more in
the mainstream. It kind of can highlight the
question of who has the right to each other
[0:50:25] [Phonetic] interested practice [0:50:26]
[Phonetic] in building worlds or in building
technologies, is it just a mainstream or the
people who can't live in to the mainstream
have the right also have that a world built
[0:50:36] [Inaudible]. So I\'92m wondering
-- \
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Rosemarie: It sounds like you know a
lot about this actually.
\b [Laughter]\
\b0 Female 3: I was wondering if you could
link it to technology issue.\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Rosemarie: Well, I'm obviously using
technology in this very broader sense and
my purpose there is to try to suggest a broad
understanding of technology is being anything
that allows a kind of -- a tool would be one
way of thinking about technology but even
that I think can be somewhat limited but some
kind of a material thing that lies between
our fleshly embodiment and the environment
that we live in and that we have to operate
in. So that kind of a definition would say
that closer form of technology that tools
are a form of technology. Language is a form
of technology. I mean we kind of know this
but the accessible technology allows a wide
range of people to use the world that was
not built originally for them is and I suggested
this but I think it's important it, it stills
in the sense that because we use it so comfortably,
because the interface does it were between
the body and the world that allows us to do
tasks and to be out in the world is so smooth
that it isn't often even noticed.\
And that's one reason I wanted to bring forward
all this varying kinds of technologies, that's
one reason I'd like to see Lady Gaga and anybody
else who wants to use, shoot wheelchairs or
feather encrusted hearing aids does so so
that there's the widest distribution and use
of technology and of course, one of the principles
of technology if that it has unintended usages.
For example, I'm not exactly directing -- answering
your question but maybe I am. For example,
the history of the Washington Metro being
built which I had mentioned briefly and gave
you some examples is particularly interesting
and emblematic. \
First of all, the Washington Metro they dug
a hole to build it in the 1970's. So it began
being built in exactly the same time that
the legislation for an accessible world started
being put forward. So the Architectural Barriers
Act was in 1968 that was the year that the
Washington Metro got started. So it grew up
and got build as a material thing while the
legislation and practices were developing.
And so it exemplary in that sense as opposed
to a kind of retro fitted public transportation
system or one that was built much later after
a lot of the design solutions and court cases,
I might add had been worked out. \
So of course, the first thing was that the
to make the Washington Metro accessible, they
said we got to have that their meaning the
advisors that I think largely came from the
disability community and advocates for disability
access said you got to have elevators. And
of course they said, "Are you kidding? We
got -- elevators cost too much. So how about
just escalators?" And the argument went, "No,
you got to have elevators because a lot of
people can't really use escalators very effectively."
I'm not sure quite but the examples are a
bit say -- I might have this a little bit
wrong but sometimes cane users, escalators
don't work really well. Certainly, you can't
take a motorize wheelchair on escalator either.
\
So they said, "Okay. How about to save money
and not build this elevators, let's -- let's
have a special van service you can call up
and you can have a van come and pick you up
and take you to an accessible station or take
you where you need to go." And a judge ruled
that that was separate but equal and that
it was not allowable and ordered them to build
the elevators and now, of course, we understand.
The argument would be why build the elevators,
there are only one or two people that are
ever going to use them. So this -- we know
this principle about sort of unintended users
or surprising consequences like rolling suitcases
for one thing. So that stands as a particular
example of how people, groups that may not
be understand themselves to being in the mainstream
can actually use accessible technology in
ways that the designers had not ever imagined.
\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b \cf0 [0:55:14]\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\li2160\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b0 \cf0 I had my most satisfying moment the
other day. I don't know if anyone follows
George Will who as you know is the conservative\'85
\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Male 4: Pundit.\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Rosemarie: Pundit, thank you.
\b [Laughter]
\b0 A conservative pundit, but George Will
also has a son who has down syndrome and he
has written really I think important things
about the rights of inclusion and the rights
of people with disabilities and his son turned
50 the other day and he wrote a series of
articles or a couple of articles, columns
about this. And I couldn't believe my good
luck because I keep making the argument that
the Washington DC Metro is fully accessible
to a wider range of people than was ever intended
and he talked about his son going to baseball
games and fishing and using the Metro and
that he knows how to use the Metro by himself
which means that the Metro is an accessible
space for transportation. We can make the
argument that it's an accessible space of
transportation up for people with developmental
disabilities. And so I was really glad to
hear that. Question?\
Female 4: \'85 the widespread implementation
of a new icon that looks like a friendly face
basically which is targeted for confidence
to also psycho social disabilities which of
course more difficult to generalized about
and support and so on and so and it's not
legible to everybody. I mean I see some commentary
in the web like what does this means \'96\
[Crosstalk] \
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Rosemarie: They started this and all
and I've been traveling.\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Female 4: Yeah, yeah. It's like -- it's
like a sort of friendly face ideas. So...
and then I think it's interesting provocation
for digital space because --\
Rosemarie: If it's to indicate something else
or is it to be to create a kind of effective
my environment right there?\
Female 4: I think that's the latter. So I
think that it's to indicate like if you're
someone who has an anxiety disorder or you're
someone who is overwhelmed by certain kind
of noise or the options of the space in a
very bureaucratic space or something and you
need, you know, some mini amount support or
something, you know, more involve like we
\'96 we \'96 or sort of aware and you can
approach it and say, you know, need something.
So I do think for the digital space again,
there are kind of supplements of that kind
of move or you sort of offer, you know, a
helping hand or you haven't sort of decided
what that is --\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Rosemarie: It's kind of a new way of
imagining assistance I guess.\
Female 4: That's right, yeah.\
Rosemarie: Or even what we might think of
any customer service.
\b [Laughter] \
\b0 Female 4: Any contemporary -- contemporary
disability and so on, yeah.\
Rosemarie: Yeah.\
Female 4: Yeah.\
Rosemarie: Oh, that's very interesting. I'll
look that up. Thank you. Please.\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Female 5: Hi. I really love this for
your beauty [0:57:59] [Phonetic].\
Rosemarie: Thank you.\
Female 5: It\'92s sweet. I wanted to like
explore a little bit more and see where the
edge was between something that's beautiful
and seeing something other than freakish and
where do you see that line and looking at
these objects.\
Rosemarie: Well, there is a lot that has been
taught and written about and created that
challenges, let's say, traditional notions
of aesthetics both in art and of course, in
-- I don't know, what might be called, you
know, feminist appearance conversations. \
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Female 5: Sure.
\b [Laughter]
\b0 \
Colin: You're so good with that.
\b [Laughter]\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b0 \cf0 Rosemarie: But in relation to some
of this art and also in particular in relation
to art that is sometimes considered sensationalist
or grotesque or surrealism which are -- are
aesthetic movements or aesthetic categories
that actually feature what we think of as
disability. I mean surrealism is about extravagant
disability. There's also quite a bit of interesting
work that's been down around as I said grotesque,
the grotesque which is a literally in aesthetic
category of hybridity. I was just at conference
in Edinburgh giving a keynote address in the
name -- talk about sensationalist. The name
of the conference was Sensualising Deformity.
It was terrific because of course what they
were doing was trying to figure out the connections
between the fantastic and surreal representation
of, let's say, otherness and the political
agendas involved in disability rights and
inclusion. \
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b \cf0 [1:00:03]\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\li2160\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b0 \cf0 And they did a really interesting
job but there's some fabulous art. I'll tell
you one of the most interesting things I didn't
included here that I've discovered recently
if you want an example of this kind of thing,
there is a British artist who works in the
medium of photography named Alexa Wright,
W-R-I-G-H-T and she has a lot of series but
this one series that she's done called After
Image is really fascinating and I've been
trying to do some work around it. She has
made portraits and I'm very interested in
portraits of people with disabilities as some
of the pictures I've suggested have or I\'92m
sure have suggested. She did a series of photographic
portraits of I think six or seven people with
phantom limb and they described -- you may
know what phantom limb is. It's the neurological
experience of an amputated body part, hence,
phantom limb. It's a really wonderful term.
\
Anyway, she talked to people with phantom
limb, amputees obviously but phantom limb
and asked them what their experience of this
phantom limb was like. And then she digitally
created that experience in the photographs.
So for example, there is a picture that I
often show of a woman seated in a chair and
one arm looks a little bit like this arm and
the other one looks a little bit like this
arm except that there's a gap between the
wrist and the elbow because that's how this
woman experiences in terms of sensation her
own body. So it's really quite fascinating
to see that and it's one of the few places
that I have seen the subjective experience
of disability represented visually. So it's
really interesting stuff. \
So these kinds of things are being discussed
all the time. There is a very interesting
sculpture up in Trafalgar Square that you
might have got a look at. I think it came
down about a year or so ago because a public
art that's rotating. They -- a sculpture called
Alison Lapper Pregnant done by Marc Quinn.
He's a very well-known British artist and
he made this white marbles nude statue of
a nude woman on a pedestal except that she's
rather significantly disabled. She has very
foreshortened arms and legs and she's pregnant.
So it's an extremely controversial content
and an extremely conventional form and operated
as a forum for a lot of interesting public
discussions about what we ought to be looking
at, who are ought to be out in public, who
ought to be having reproducing and what not
to be. So it was a very provocative in every
sense piece of public art where disability
was doing something in the world to get some
good conversations up in a democratic order.
\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Female 5: I'm curious what your thoughts
are with respect to financial access to disability
technology and the impact of potentially mainstreaming
disability technology having on potentially
technology that's necessary for people who
maybe more marginalize or wouldn\'92t fit
within than that mold. I personally known
people not to get hearing aids because they
don't feel like they can afford it which is
more simple or probably less expensive technology
and then you're talking about we've seen some
very elegant prosthesis pieces and things
like that my understanding of not having any
experience myself is that that is not necessarily
accessible to most and if we're trying to
create a more accessible world, a more universally
accessible world, how all that place together
both whether commoditizing it makes it more
accessible or not sort of accessible through
health insurance and some things like that.\
Rosemarie: Oh this is a very important question;
of course, it has to do with the allocation
of resources. And those things are historically
and geographically quite specific. I mean
California, for example, as you all know is
about financially just sinking in the ocean
and so what -- the first thing that tends
to happen is that services for people with
disabilities get cut and there is also a kind
of hierarchy of deservedness that operates
perhaps not intentionally but functionally.
For example, we tend to think that categories
like disabled veterans sort of deserve better
services and accommodations than say, people
who have disabilities that involve volition
like addiction. \
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b \cf0 [1:05:09]\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\li2160\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b0 \cf0 So it's very complicated in that
sense and as I said I'm telling a very positive
story, my own senses that the more universal
technology becomes, the cheaper it's going
to become, the more available it's going to
become. But there will never be a universal
solution to every particular accommodation
need. So while -- I don't even know how Aimee
Mullins gets her legs or Oscar Pistorius or
how much they cost but there are really kind
of prototypes and we know, those of us who
know anything about technology that the prototype
always is expensive and exclusive and that
the more universalize to any kind of piece
of technology becomes, the cheaper and more
accessible it becomes. \
Here's one example in my view is that we are
developing sort of better and better and cheaper
and cheaper but also in some ways more and
more expensive forms of addressing say, hard
of hearing and deafness like cochlear implants
which are medicalized as opposed to a piece
of technology that you just sort of stick
on are extremely important. What I'd like
to see is an alternative less technological,
lower tech and less medicalized solution to
the universal experience of hearing loss.
And anyone with a grandparent knows what I'm
talking about here. And that is and this would
be really inexpensive, frankly, is to start
teaching sign language in all schools as part
of the mandatory curriculum from kindergarten
forward so that all people universally would
have some use and knowledge to one degree
or another of sign language so that when people
transition in to the inevitable hearing, part
of hearing status that they will, that they
can simply understand themselves as moving
from one form of communication if they had
always been deaf or hard of hearing in to
another form of communication rather than
relying on expensive technology. \
Again, anyone with grandparents also knows
that has seen the scene of granddad taking
that hearing aid out if his ear and he either
throwing it across the room or flushing it
down the toilet because it doesn't -- it doesn't
do what we would expect it to do. Part of
the narrative of that is that it restores
recognizable hearing the way it was and of
course, it doesn't. And so in that sense,
that's pat of the limitation of technology.
So if we all use sign language as the anthropologist,
medical anthropologist Nora Groce observed
when she studied deafness on Martha's Vineyard
in the 19th century, we all use sign language,
deafness as a disability would disappear.
So that's -- that's one way of addressing
access without relying on expensive
produced technology. With that said, I want
everyone to have an iPhone with dictation
on it.
\b [Laughter]\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b0 \cf0 [Crosstalk]\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Female 6: Yeah, I do. And it's interesting
because thinking about the whole motion of
using insurance to purchase or perhaps not
having available insurance to purchase these
items, I know a young woman who uses communication
device because she's non-verbal and it's very
expensive. It's very heavy, difficult to use
got an iPad. She could buy six iPads for the
price of these communication devices --\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Rosemarie: Yeah, that's interesting.\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Female 6: But the insurance company wouldn't
pay for the iPad because it's not use just
for communication because it has other uses.
But they had --\
Rosemarie: But that's what -- that's a glitch
right now but I think that's the kind of answer
that we want.\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Female 5: Right.\
Rosemarie: So that's what universal accessibility
is basically about --\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Male 5: But it's not just the creation
of the device because we have the device that
is --\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Rosemarie: Right.\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Male 5: ... infrastructure around that
and accessibility for individuals and say
we need to look these different things.\
Male 6: That's been an interesting problems
with technology where we\'92re accustoms to
as opposed to purposely have solution for
little things like an -- [1:09:45] [Inaudible].
We\'92ll go for something that\'92s off the
shelf and use massively or just really sacrifices
for pulling up the cost could be or supports
getting better. It's going to be more like
we used to. Can I ask one back on to this
so just one -- \
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Rosemarie: Please.\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Male 6: ... more question which is -- I
feel like you made the point very well about
the sort of benefits of universal design sort
of the inclusion of these communities as the
way that we're all get benefit and you made
kind of the point through the art of power
of inclusiveness in terms of getting people
out of the house or out in to public and sharing
their unique perspective.\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b \cf0 [1:10:20]\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\li2160\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\b0 \cf0 And I wonder also to various points
whether how far if the economic argument of
sort of diversity and inclusiveness and getting
all of these other communities which would
otherwise often being excluded from various
workplaces in to -- in to the market [1:10:36]
[Phonetic] places ideas goes against this
argument whether it's hey, it's not about,
you know, ethical inclusion. It's about \'96
this is about money. We're generating job.
We're creating livelihoods and we're adding
in kind of a capacity for innovation that
we otherwise we not have.\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Rosemarie: That's exactly right. In a
democratic order, we should strive to have
everyone included in these public spaces in
order to exercise the obligations and the
rights of citizenship. And one of the rights
of citizenship is employment and access to
education. And one of the obligations of citizenship
is contribution in some way and it's much
better to have people in the workforce than
not. So which is not to say that we should
do way to social security and services for
people with disabilities and it's a complicated
world but I think that's exactly what we\'92re
after. And the only way that it can occur
is through a built environment that is accessible.
I mean that a disabled person can be in this
room is kind of the first thing. \
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Male 6: Well, yeah. \
Rosemarie:
\b [Laughter]
\b0 With that.\
[Crosstalk]\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\li2160\fi-2160\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Rosemarie: I'll be happy if anyone has
other questions or comments to stick around
for a few minutes. Thank you. \
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\cf0 Male 6: So please join me for a round
of applause.
\b [Clapping]\
[1:12:19] End of Audio\
\b0 \
\pard\pardeftab720\sl240\ql\qnatural\pardirnatural
\fs22 \cf0 \
\pard\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\ql\qnatural\pardirnatural
\cf0 \
\pard\pardeftab720\sl240\ql\qnatural\pardirnatural
\pard\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\ql\qnatural\pardirnatural
\cf0 \
\pard\pardeftab720\sl240\ql\qnatural\pardirnatural
\pard\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\ql\qnatural\pardirnatural
\cf0 \
\pard\pardeftab720\sl240\ql\qnatural\pardirnatural
\pard\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\ql\qnatural\pardirnatural
\cf0 \
\pard\tqc\tx4680\tqr\tx9360\pardeftab720\sl240\qr\pardirnatural
\cf0 PAGE \\* MERGEFORMAT 23\
\pard\tqc\tx4680\tqr\tx9360\pardeftab720\sl240\ql\qnatural\pardirnatural
\cf0 \
\pard\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\ql\qnatural\pardirnatural
\
\pard\tx2160\pardeftab720\sl340\sa200\qj\pardirnatural
\fs24 \cf0 \
}